hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
points in Phaedrus speech the very first
speech in the symposium is that long
brings out the best in the one who is
doing the loving the one who feels love
you might actually say that this is the
key theme of his speech it's not
actually where he begins since he starts
by talking about how love is so ancient
but it's really the core of his speech
and as we're going to see it's going to
lead to one of the most interesting
images within his speech which tends to
be rather conventional you know making
allusions to a bunch of things in
mythology and legends but he's got this
image of the army of lovers that we'll
come back to in a moment now he's saying
that love brings out the best in the
longer so he's ignoring any sort of
counter examples that might be given
where a person feeling love or desire
eros in this case is going to be
motivated to do bad things we'll see
that get taken up in the later speeches
and all videos on that sort of thing
coming out as well but let's concentrate
for a moment on how love would actually
bring out the best in the lovers so
Phaedra says that it motivates us it
renders us able or or
turns us towards a certain kind of life
the highest the best life and so it
doesn't just make us good towards each
other or good for each other it actually
brings us towards what is best in life
how does that happen well this is you
know the sort of thing that we see
happening quite often in cultural
productions ranging from you know love
poetry in the ancient period all the way
to you know modern romantic comedies he
says that it works in part by causing
the lover to emulate or to you know take
a certain bearing from the good and also
to have contempt or quite literally
shame iswho nay towards the the bad or
the ignoble the ice of the ice cross
there's a little play on words occurring
in the Greek in there so when a person
loves what this does is takes them out
of their ordinary frame of reference
where they might actually not feel
contempt for the band where they might
not feel shame in terms of certain
actions that when they're placed in the
context of a love relationship where
they desire another and want the beloved
to look at them in a certain way they
will feel a sense of shame or where
they're not properly motivated towards
the good they're motivated perhaps
towards some other lesser good something
that is just merely pleasurable but not
that good
and as such not the good that's being
acknowledged within this framework and
we can think of all sorts of examples
where people you know want to make
themselves a better person we have that
that lion that you see I want to be a
better man I want to be a better woman
for you that's exactly what he's talking
about here so this process he says leads
to great makalah and Noble Agatha deeds
Erika things that are done things that a
person accomplishes not just great and
noble talk not just great and noble
imaginings but actually doing
something and he says that this this you
know is important both for individuals
and for entire political communities
that you know you know in order to
accomplish great and noble deeds which
are part of the highest and best life
you have to have a proper motivation for
that so what can supply that motivation
here's where we can another interesting
some point that he's bringing up law he
says this this desire of the beloved for
the longer that there there feeling this
effective state that there being almost
possessed by it works more effectively
he says then three other types of
motivation and this doesn't cover the
entire gamut of possible human motives
maybe we put revenge in there or other
things but this actually does cover
quite a large ground wealth Pluto Singh
in Greek the the desire to earn money
not only for the sake of staying alive
or perhaps building something but you
know even this inexhaustible desire that
wealth can bring about in certain people
you can get a lot done with money you
can pay people to do things but money
itself will not accomplish as much as
love will at least in terms of this it's
it's a less intrinsic motivator we might
say for for the person who lost the man
in fact they might be willing to give up
lots of wealth in order to you know seek
out time or occasions or provide gifts
or you know even just you know pave a
path for the person who they're in love
with honor team a very important
conception for the Greeks we would talk
about it these days in terms of like
reputation or respect even self-respect
in a certain respect celebrity the way
that we talk about it could be part of
what the Greeks call honour in their own
time and people will do a lot of crazy
stuff for the sake of getting other
people to think a certain way of them
and to talk about them that way thinking
about all the stunts that people have
gone through
and you know things ranging from reality
television to social media to publicity
stunts but Phaedra says and then by the
way the Greeks were you know we're
probably not any less crazy in their
time we've ever had a hard time when it
comes to that sort of thing what
Phaedra's saying no matter how effective
of a motivator
the desire to be respected the desire to
be looked at in a certain positive light
or not to be looked at at a negative
light is it's not as strong as the force
of love love can get the lover to do
more it can orient the person more
consistently towards great and noble
deeds then can the desire for honor or
to maintain honor volume-wise family or
family connections being being in a
certain family matrix families are
indeed one of our most important
institutions and they were even more so
in the time of the Greeks so there
wasn't as much mobility at that time
your family was the people who would
look to in part for this this conception
of honor
but there was also a certain intimacy
within the family that you know you
wouldn't have in the the wide world of
the polis or the political community and
family can get us to do a lot of things
that are good and a lot of things that
are bad it is a strong motivator but
it's not as strong Phaedrus again says
as the force of love and you know if you
think about how this works there are
many instances where somebody goes
against their family because they are in
a romantic relationship or an erotic
relationship with somebody else so this
is a very interesting set of points
let's go a little bit deeper how how
does law actually work this way he says
there's two main things that this leads
to now of course you know he's running
through the speech it's sort of a
headlong pace he's not saying bullet
point in a bullet point B or anything
like that but we can separate them out
with that the lover doesn't want
look bad they don't want to engage in
anything shameful anything that will
take away from the image that they
believe that the beloved the person who
they have affection towards the person
who they desire the person that they're
infatuated with they don't want to
affect that image that that person has
of them negatively so what are they
going to do as a result they're gonna
behave in a good way they're gonna do
the right thing at the right time
they're going to be motivated to not do
anything shameful anything that would
bring a probe reom down upon themselves
anything that would make them look
stupid or foolish or you know the
example that he has here is is cowardly
for the ancient Greeks at least for men
but also for women to a certain degree I
mean you can see this in the plays and
the other cultural productions the the
notion of cowardice was a sufficient
motivator for many people don't be a
coward get out there in the battlefield
lines it was pretty scary to go out to
battle right now there can be many other
things that might scare a person as well
you know one of the things that they
bring up quite quite frequently in
examples of this sort of thing is what
do you do when you're on a boat and
there's a storm at sea because there's
no Coast Guard and there weren't a whole
lot of safety provisions at that time or
lifejackets there's a good possibility
that if your ship founders you're going
down with it that's when you see who
really is courageous and who isn't the
lumber at least with respect to the
beloved is going to act rightly now you
know if the beloved is a rather
unscrupulous character maybe they only
care if the the longer acts rightly
towards them but that's not the way most
people tend to behave that's not the way
Phaedrus is construing this it's more
like when you're actually in love with
somebody and you care more about how
they see you then then how all the rest
of the world sees you or you know what
the consequences are for yourself
you're going to be willing to do noble
and fine actions precisely so that you
can
look good in the eyes of the blood the
way he says it is that here we go I will
say this of the lover should he be
discovered in some inglorious after an
abject submission to use if she could
better bear that anyone father friends
who you will should witness this than
his beloved and the same thing holds
good of the beloved the beloved doesn't
want to be seen by the lover in an
unworthy state there's a little bit of
an imbalance there which are going to
explore in the next video having to do
specifically with this beloved love
beloved lover relationship but that's
one important way in which the person is
motivated the other is that the longer
will in fact sacrifice themselves not
just their money not just a reputation
but even their life for the sake of the
beloved he brings up three classical
examples ones that a Greek audience
would be intimately familiar with ones
that we see appearing in dramatic
productions alec estes is a woman whose
whose husband is told you're going to
die but if you can escape death an early
death by the way in his prime of his
life if in fact somebody will agree to
die in your place he asks his parents
and his parents say oh we like beating
alive and he says hey look you know I'm
young you're old it wouldn't be that
much longer for you to live anyway and
they say you know we love you son but we
don't love you that much you know he's
starting to realize who his real friends
family or lover yes it's his wife I'll
cast us who says I'll die in your place
and that for the Greeks is you know sort
of a stumbling block and a stopping
point they see that sort of thing
and there's a there's a certain glorious
aspect about that another prime example
that he gives is that of Achilles
Achilles was really kind of the golden
boy of Troy
yeah you know Devine himself practically
the best warrior among them you know
wonderful to look at well-spoken and
telogen he's got everything going for
him and he also has a wonderful
companion who he is in love with
petropolis now Petropolis is an older
companion and so petropolis is actually
in a certain respect the the lover and
Achilles is the beloved but when ctrl+
goes out and fights on Achilles armor to
try to you know shore up the Greek
defense because Hector the Trojan
champion is just mowing people down
Petropolis is killed and this is what
actually brings achilles to be willing
to go back into battle Agamemnon had
ticked him off unfortunately for the
Greeks by really acting like a jerk
whole long story there but Achilles goes
out recovers Patroclus is body and then
you know wants to avenge petrópolis and
he's warned if you do this you're gonna
die he does it anyway in part because
it's an expression of his love for the
one who loved him the other case in
point that that Phaedrus brings up is
Orpheus and Orpheus is kind of a a
failure in this case Orpheus is not
truly a lover he goes down to Hades he
goes down to the land of the dead but he
goes down alive and there's a whole
interesting story there as well when he
goes down he manages to bring back
you're a dis his wife but it's not
really your it is it's just a shadow a
shade of her ass Chios and she
disappears so he doesn't get the beloved
object in part because he's not willing
to die he's not willing to go down to
Hades and die for her he goes down alive
he kind of tricks death right so this
leads us to something that is not coming
up last in the speech but I wanted to
treat last here this really startling
image that Phaedrus produces which may
in fact have some historical foundation
the army or the city of lovers and blood
of pairs of people in this case pairs of
men who have this relationship with each
other and who are going to perform at a
much higher level who who could be
totally relied upon because their
fighting side by side with their lover
or with their beloved so they don't want
to look bad and they will sacrifice
themselves for the the person who's
who's next to them phaedra suggests that
this would be an unstoppable military
force he doesn't really flesh out the
idea of the city but the idea was there
would be that this would somehow be an
unstoppable or unsurmountable City as
well all of this goes back to this idea
that love is capable of bringing out the
best in the person who truly feels love